the next generation's the opposite of
the original series because the first
season sucks and the third season starts
to be good i think the first title is
better
don't you don't think the first season
that is absurd it was awkwardly acted i
thought that that is absurd it's funny
it all starts the best of both worlds is
the greatest achievement in the history
of television until game of thrones
and after the best and after yeah and
after the best of both worlds it becomes
a great television that's an episode the
best of both worlds it's two episodes um
which one is locutis of borg yeah oh my
goodness yeah yeah borg was such a good
episode
it's unbelievable and after that you
know they they brought the high collar
in they got the cooler phasers they got
the new model everything got cool but
man those first couple seasons it's the
love boat in space
this is this is this is our western
canyon
the future generations need to know star
trek disney man
i posted this clip because there are so
many people who are naysayers
i'm surprised there are people who would
watch a show like this but also be like
i'm not watching star trek
yeah and i'm just like no no you don't
understand we're not talking about
wouldn't it be cool to be in a spaceship
with lasers we're talking about
naval tradition we're talking about
military officers defending of the
freedom and civil liberties of
individuals going to planets where they
experience terrorism the uh that line uh
when data goes to picard and says i'm
having trouble understanding you know
the conduct of these people they're
engaging in terrorism and then picard
says i do not uh subscribe to the belief
that political power is derived from the
barrel of a gun and then data says but
if you look at history in the names like
two real examples but then fictional
future examples where terror actually
worked and picard's like these are
questions that humanity struggles with
like that's why the show is good yeah
the philosophical and moral explorations
and i was being somewhat facetious but
there is a component to the fact that
star trek did often include the great
work so they referenced shakespeare you
have episodes about you know greek
mythology they really included things
that today most people are completely
unaware of which is sad but you can
actually like learn about them from star
trek and then start to do a deep dive
because kids aren't learning it in
school that's right yeah i do have a
special soft spot for like laser beams
though when they like rough house with
an alien costume i do too one of my
least favorite things about all the new
iterations of star trek starting with
the jj abrams and all the way through
picard right now is that they've
basically gotten rid of phasers and
everything's just a star wars style
blaster now lasers to stun man they call
them phasers but they don't have beams
they're like little bubbles they were
little clickers the uh in the next
generation they were miniaturized little
clickers they would just point which
would be very difficult to aim oh yeah
you couldn't i think every time i watch
the next generation i just think you
just killed everybody
you'll see like what is this i wonder if
they are themselves that yeah well one
of the things that was positive about it
and the reason uh my dad used to watch
it with us as kids is because his view
he told us when we got older is that it
was very much a positive influence
because
they would exhaust every peaceful option
they could but they would still fight
when they had to so it wasn't completely
pacifist but they were all about seeking
the non-violent solution when possible
and they didn't hesitate in the face of
of threat they would fight immediately
they would fight when they needed to
yeah um the original series was so
pro-american that
i grew up in the next generation i love
the next generation right i'm a sucker
for all star trek
but the original series is
like morally and philosophically so much
better because it's deeper and richer it
was at the height of real sci-fi
especially the first season and a half
where they really were asking all these
questions for the first time and you
have these episodes where like
captain kirk will beam down to a planet
that is utopia everyone there has all
the food they can eat they have it never
rains you know there's no hail there's
no weather everything is perfect and
he'll look around and say this place is
crap i'm gonna go i'm gonna go destroy
the computer that has made you all
mental slaves yeah and he'll go to he'll
ruin their utopia to set them free and
you you talk about things you can't do
on television now you could never say
that utopia is bad because people aren't
free that's so true that's interesting
this is what people have pointed out
have you been following the new picard
oh yeah of course uh
i don't think i'm gonna watch i yeah i
didn't even bother i didn't mind season
one of picard um but season two for
those that aren't aware is about uh you
know what is it the 2022s or whatever
the 2020 yeah 20 20 22 20s or whatever
2024. 20
well uh so the star trek crew picard
which are in the future have to
transport themselves back in time to
2024 because something happened that
turned earth into a human supremacist
planet right and i'm just like yo
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
political propaganda it's absolutely
absurd by the way and i've seen i've
seen every episode that's out so far i
can't help myself but
i'm such a sucker for nostalgia
and the first season of picard is
terrible but when you get to the end and
we get the actual data picard death
scene that we were robbed of in the
films you go yeah i'll follow you guys
through the gates of hell give me tell
me how all humans are fascists i'm in i
want to i want to know yeah they never
talk about vulcan supremacists it's
interesting but vulcans don't have
institutional powers so they're not the
first thing is it's clear that the
picard series is just you know member
berries
remember the borg remember pick up and
then like they meet everyone and it's
like oh like yo just give me a series
that follows deep space nine in in the
continuity and we can move beyond the
dominion or whatever for those that are
fans and uh but instead what they're
doing is
we're going back in time again
and the the characters they bring back
you know so uh you've watched the first
two episodes i'd imagine of picard first
four yeah first four already out man
i've been working too much um but q does
not feel like you you know when when
he's like this is not a lesson picard
it's penance i'm like come on yeah he
was the guy who showed up with the
mariachi band smoking a cigar and
dancing not some like torture of some
great message or anything he's just
chaotic yeah you're not with him you're
not you're not allowed to have fun right
this is what's different now you're not
allowed everything you watch ads at the
super bowl
and they're all they're all important
the words you would use for the the ad
agent they would say this was an
important ad
this was a beautiful ad to the super
bowler this was a touching ad at the
super bowl yeah but what are the really
funny ads at the super bowl i'm getting
people keep writing in telling me that
the jeremy's razor shameless plug you
can see it i hate harry.com
commercial
people
hundreds of people are writing it this
is the best commercial i've ever seen
i'm very proud of the commercial it's
not the best commercial that's ever been
made why they're responding that way is
because it is the best commercial that's
been made in a decade because it's the
first commercial in a decade where you
can just laugh at it and that's good and
my fault like what's that movie fall guy
is that what it is with ryan ryan
reynolds fall guy is that what it's
called no is that what the movie's
called which one when some movie that
just came out where's the project
almost like produced like on that level
and then i just want to add you know
my uh compliments to uh the commercial
were so good the daily wire actually i
picked that one up pushed my video out
you know because because you know yeah
well good commentary from tim yeah we
need more like that you mentioned these
uh these people seeing their
advertisements as important and this is
one of these things that if they could
just step out of their little box for
three seconds they would understand how
ridiculous it is just the phrase like
this is going to be the most important
coca-cola commercial but let me let me i
want to go back to uh let's back to star
trek
how and why does a network a company say
we have this this ip this popular ip we
have decades of storytelling and movies
and series
let's just put them in 2024 to fight
trump i know why that's nothing to do
with any of the history like if you want
to make a show about time travelers who
fight donald trump make the show i i'd
probably watch it anyway just to see
what you're talking about but why make
picard do it and they and then star trek
discovery stacey abram shows up as the
president of united earth
wow oh she actually got cheated out of
that election
who are they speaking to themselves
they're speaking to themselves i
honestly wonder if they're even doing
that it's funny we were oh man i really
wanted to get into this earlier but it
blew past us and now is the perfect time
to segue to it you were discussing the
the western canon and
part of why it's so important to tell
good stories is because it's where
people get their morality from yes it
helps to give people moral precepts and
principles but ultimately people are
going to act on the basis of who they
admire and the stories that they know
and so part of why they need to change
these stories is because though they
weren't perfect some of them actually
had decent values and so what you need
to do is recon retcon them and shove
your own values into it so that you can
control people this is what people say
because uh i tweeted a video from uh the
next generation
where uh
the the uh an admiral starfleet orders
data to give up his child to the you
know the state and picard is like no and
he risks his career he says men of good
conscience will defy orders
you know to watch to have to to compel a
man to give his child to the state not
while i'm captain and i was like man
that was so awesome and then everyone
said the new picard series he would do
the opposite he would say for the for
the betterment of the family we must
allow you know and and for safety and
security that's what that's that's the
message we'd get across now from picard
like his values are gone yeah and that's
kind of sad to me the character should
have been left left just as as as it was
but they can't they can't do it they
can't they need to talk because they
can't create they can't make new things
they have to pervert what other people
have already rod
this is true which is why
they take this long historic this this
long history
history show and then change it but it's
also they want to destroy the the the
character picard represented the values
he represented they want to take him
away as a role model from people who
believed in these civil libertarian
values this is one of the reasons that
we got into making movies at daily wires
because so much content that exists now
exists to tell you that you don't
deserve
these characters and so like you know
you see it in these superhero movies uh
quite a lot like you watch the beginning
of uh in game and captain america who in
the first in the first avengers movie
captain america says you know there's
only one god and he doesn't wear tights
and he's he's a character from the 1940s
yep
who goes to
lies about his age to go fight the nazis
he wears red white and blue and
literally is called america that's the
character and he gets frozen in ice and
he wakes up in the 20th century and by
in game it opens up and he's in this
counseling session and we have to have
the reveal that the person who is
sharing an insight with him is a married
gay man a gay married gay man i would
say a gay married gay man because gay
men have been married throughout all of
human history and it didn't mean what we
mean now right
it's a gay married gay man and what why
do they do why do that
you say well it's to be inclusive is to
show people that even gay married gay
men have a place in the world but that's
not why they do it if that's why they
did it i might even go okay we can live
that isn't the motive the motive is to
say
all of you red state flyover maga hat
wearin
love america wear red white and blue
guys
literal captain america doesn't belong
to you you don't get to claim him he
belongs to us we can give him any set of
values that we want in fact if you watch
that whole marvel avengers arc
remarkably
captain america
becomes the uh the renegade character
during civil war
and iron man tony stark becomes the
representative of state power like it's
a it's an unbelievable inversion of
those characters because they don't know
what the characters mean it's not
because they don't know it's because
they actually really want the
character's standard hold on are you
you're not familiar with the captain
america nomad arc i'm not no captain
america
uh i don't i'm not i haven't read all
this stuff it was before my time but
there was a period where captain america
abandoned the name and called himself
nomad because you know the point they
were making was if you truly believe in
america you don't always stand by the
government for whatever it does sure so
you know that's a general idea i
actually thought civil war was fairly
well done i mean captain america was the
guy saying
i'm not going to sign over my rights to
the state i'm you know i'm an individual
and tony stark is is a corporate war
monger who's like
the state you know is right science i
know you know we have to
i thought the the the politics in that
were were fairly good albeit the marvel
movies are like kindergarten grade
entertainment yeah captain america's uh
war propaganda was created to fight
nazis and get people right about world
war ii and keep that in mind forever
moving forward that was war propaganda
well i i want to make this point part of
why it's so instructive that is captain
america is because the left has this
fetish for protect projecting their
values onto the people who fought the
second world war so they're always
claiming that they're the ones fighting
nazi uh you'll see memes floating around
of the brave young men storming normandy
and it says this is antifa trying to
fight nazis um i did a cartoon about
this a while ago called fighting nazis
then verse now and what it was based on
was this exact premise because my
grandfather fought in the second world
war he
played a very key role in ensuring that
the
officers at the flossenberg
concentration camp were caught and
placed on trial he really had an
incredible and harrowing tour
and he would not use your pronouns i
mean this is not somebody who's going to
uh or would you make a comply with
left-wing values yeah exactly i made a
whole cartoon about this point but it's
so funny to me that the left wants to
claim that they own these people even
though if if they were alive today and
those who are alive today from that era
don't agree with them at all if they
even think about them yeah yeah i wonder
if um
the speed at which we're communicating
the bifurcation of culture will just
it's leading to
something some say peaceful divorce
perhaps because of the internet it could
it could be something we haven't seen in
the past or civil war maybe but i just
don't see how
there's any reconciliation with the the
modern iteration of the polit the left
sphere of influence because the things
they believe are just not aligned with
reality i think it comes to the
individual clearing like having slowing
down their thoughts because if your mind
is moving super rapidly with the
information like a car traveling so fast
on the road a minor
uh variation in the wheel will send that
thing flying off course and the same
thing happens to your brain if it's on
overload activity all the time so it's
really
i don't think there's a top-down
solution it'll be up to people to
control themselves
and let this stuff flow past them while
still acknowledging it
are we doomed or is it going to be all
right i don't think we can both i think
things get bad for a while i think
things might get bad for a while i
wouldn't say that we're doomed though i
don't i mean it's pretty it's a pretty
easy prediction to say that things are
going to get bad for a while but also in
the long run i don't know how things are
going to turn out
my mentality is very much like i got to
be honest with everybody um
you know i had it bad most of my life
you know up until my mid 20s when you
know for the next you know a few years
my career started taking off and things
started generally improving and so for
me my editor's always kind of just been
like yo all of this is icing on the cake
you know if if if people were unwilling
to fight for their values and their va
and everything fell apart
the food shortages get really bad and i
wake up you know in six months homeless
and with no food i'd be like oh you know
been there done that i'm not really
worried about it granted i don't have a
family so a lot of people who do would
be much more terrified of something like
that if tomorrow all the things were
gone i'd worked for all my life oh yeah
if you had to start again with just your
children and your wife
oh here you go
yeah
no i just
there's a i think it was zubi who said
this that if you took all of the
property for from every single person
and then gave everyone you know ten
thousand dollars the people who were
rich before would become rich and the
people who were poor before would would
become poor for the most part this is a
hard conversation maybe we can go to the
after show because it really comes down
to eugenics like this this concept of
eugenics where it came from and what it
all means like the the fact that people
even think of themselves as an elite
class and that there's everybody else
and that
or or the plebeians is what the romans
called them and then there's the central
intelligentsia i don't know is that real
like we just like you just stated well a
lot of things are real a lot of things
that are unseemly are real but not
everything that's real is is um
not everything that's true is capital t
truth like i think that one of the
problems this kind of comes back to the
ideology dogma thing we we sometimes
take observations that we make
or measurements that we make things that
are true and because you're not allowed
to say a lot of things that are true in
our culture right now um it's it's uh
subversive to even think about them and
the result the result of that is that
whenever you do engage with those ideas
you're engaging in them in the worst
places possible with people who are like
probably taking them to the furthest
extreme and it becomes easy for us to so
you know like you become a eugenicist in
your mind like hitler was in the 20s and
30s or something which is
obviously a grave evil thing i mean it's
it's obviously true
it's an obvious truth that simply
because something is generally true it's
not specifically true that because uh
for example
asian americans have a higher iq than
than white americans just to avoid any
of the races you're not allowed to talk
about
there's nothing racist about talking ill
of asians right so asians statistically
higher iq than white people that that
the smartest person in the world could
be a white person uh and it would still
be true that statistically that
statistically agents have a higher iq so
you end up in a situation where the the
truth about the general truth
can sometimes blind us to the specific
truth
and that's where i think that's where a
lot of tribalism a lot of isms come from
that that aren't good you get into the
nuance of what is what does it mean to
be asian are you referring specifically
to like southeast asian are you
referring to the philippines are you
referring to india of course and then
those things all play a role i think the
problem with stereotypes is that people
hear the word asian they exclude indians
but particularly in europe you say the
word asian and they include indians so
we're not even you know we're not even
necessarily hitting at the same points
yeah i agree i i'm only making the point
that when we talk about these difficult
issues like eugenics uh are some people
are some people born with advantages of
course they are people are born with
high iqs and people are born with low
iqs more people are born with low iqs
than people are born with high iqs one
of the challenges in in ordering
societies and not letting is not judging
people based on those generalities but
that doesn't mean that there aren't
specific
realities that people
that people are different there are
people born with advantages you can
leave iq out of it iq is the hardest
thing to talk about because everyone is
the smartest person they know it's just
your your own your ability to perceive
someone smarter than you is capped by
your own intelligence
but it's very easy for me to acknowledge
that like lebron james is better than
basketball than i am and you could say
if i practiced really hard i could be
better than no i couldn't if i practiced
really hard i could be better than me
but no amount of practice will make me
better than lebron if lebron didn't
practice and i did practice he would
still be better than me now if we played
a game of
uh
lebron and i play a game of pig and
instead of playing pig we just play puh
and lebron says whoever wins this game
of puh you know gets a million dollars
i might win the million dollars every
now and then he misses and every now and
then i don't
but if you make it pit
his chances go up exponential
exponentially if you make it pig they go
up erratically if you make it hoarse i
will never win statistically ever
there's no world where i will ever win
that he has those advantages there's no
question about those advantages thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you